I mean this girl's ever like man boost
yeah finger on that thing do that we do
it yeah yeah you got a great pair of
tits or squeeze the answer is in the
comments Brunel there must be I don't
know man come here sir okay be funny
feel like have like huge man moves
thank you what kind of overweight or
something well no in your way and your
girlfriend like merely to just started
groping there's like be like doing but
then you like in like a Yankee but wait
there's one what's worse if they do that
like what about your boobs normal motor
boy your ass this why would they do that
that's the thing is it is it is that a
thing it's everything is everything just
like is that thing you do let's not talk
about that conversations leading to that
so let's just cut straight to it if you
were just like kind of trying to gauge
our reaction so you can care how many
buddies have you motorboated project a
lot of but I've been through a lot of us
do I have a not am i I mean okay uh
seriously the think about it what would
you both make you more uncomfortable a
girl groping your manboobs or a girl
groping like blue I mean this is like
you know I prefer not to have things go
near the latest areas a sealer is not a
very attractive area from now your
unless your game let me need it if
you're gay
oh if they shave in one non whack big
room the brand wine bed properly why cuz
normal men don't wipe is progress great
men we don't have time to work just like
you know smear our bathrooms is that
what you do yeah no I I'm admitting I do
that yes me and Ken bold everyone there
is weird
yeah we